c'est une info à propos de jean-marie
bigard il était invité chez sud radio ce
week-end et la réconciliation entre
muriel robin et lui c'est pas pour tout
de suite apparemment il fut parler de sa
tournée de ses sketches qui sont décriés
depuis quelques mois il n'a pas mâché
ses mots concernant muriel robin c'est
vrai que c'est un petit peu chaud entre
eux puisque tout était parti de la
fameuse blague de jean marie bigard sur
notre plateau voilà il s'était dit très
peiné jean-marie des attaques de muriel
robin ce que muriel robin avait répondu
sur son site internet
elle nie leur amitié jean-marie bon
moment quand il dit que nous sommes amis
nous avons débuté en somme nous nous
sommes de ce fait beaucoup croisé avions
des amis communs mais je n'ai pas vu
jean-marie depuis 96 c'est à dire depuis
23 ans
nous nous sommes nous ne sommes pas du
tout amis et c'est vrai que là jean
marie apparemment il l'a mauvaise auprès
de muriel robin regarde la figure de
proue du machisme enfin un petit peu
mais tellement joli mais tellement
gentil tellement assumer que les vraies
femmes n'en prennent pas ombrage
il ya que les [ __ ] qui veulent
avoir des couilles comme nous et être
aussi con que les hommes qui gueule
après moi beaucoup de chômeurs y allant
d'un c'est dur voilà qu'est ce que vous
en pensez mais c'est bien nous on a
connu jean marie bien bigard à europe 1
dans les pieds dans le plat à zurich
avec moi valérie bénaïm et moi il nous
appelait régulièrement la [ __ ] la
[ __ ]
on a les deux tout le monde était mort
d'homme à petit parfois fille et tout le
monde était mort de rire il y avait pas
mort d'homme moi je me suis pas sentie
discriminée
je me suis pas senti choqué je crois que
c'était un peu grossier un peu flou mais
un peu lourdingue
mais il était très courtois avec valérie
n'y avait aucun problème
effectivement aujourd'hui on n'a plus
droit de dire quelque chose quand on est
un hétéro bof comme comme jean marie
bigard blanche gardin pourrait le dire
par exemple elle lui dira espèce de
kaunas l espèce de [ __ ] espèce de
traîner donc je pense qu'il n'y a pas
suffit maintenant c'est lumineux serre
et chaque communauté a le droit de rire
d'elle-même
voilà mathieu mathieu wilma mathieu
n'est pas parce que j'adore mais drogba
et ça m'ennuie de dire parce que
vraiment je l'adoré je lui ai écrit
souvent des textos dansante a très bien
avec mon ami mais j'ai personnellement
vu de temps et de noyelles et autant
avec jean-marie on s'entend plaisait
peur qu'elle m'en vais un peu
surréaliste il a mis ensemble en ce
moment le rhône qu'elle se donne un
petit peu comme ça de défendre est de
toutes les femmes de 2,2 elle appelle
les ministres
voilà ça reste aussi une humoriste et
aujourd'hui elle prend elle prend ça
très au sérieux et c'est bien mais de là
tout jeter dans le bain y compris jean
marie bigard café justement toute sa
carrière sur le fait de jouer un peu le
beauf comme sana aujourd'hui le faire
passer au premier degré pour ce qu'il
n'est pas ça m'ennuie un peu les gens
que mal robin va un petit peu trop dans
son nouveau rôle de passe et
d'humoristes aujourd'hui à femmes mieux
ministre du féminisme c'est un petit peu
chier en ciel à elle a été très marqué
par le roulage ou jacqueline chauvary
est devenu être chiante et non voilà je
vous dis j'aime beaucoup les deux phases
aller dire que tu me drucker va mais
j'ai la vérité c'est vrai que muriel
robin mine de rien elle a un rôle à
jouer et que l le jouet le joue plutôt
bien et le fait d'avoir joué jacqueline
sauvage pensa à fait certain technique
d'un coup à l'homme c'est pas une raison
pour but conjugée systématiquement les
autres étant dur envers parce que bigard
comme il le dit très justement est ce
qu'il dit et ce qu'il fait c'est un gros
nounours il a toujours été respectueux
dans la vie envers les femmes
donc là je trouve que le jugement est
extrêmement 2 minimum que ce que dit ma
fille et quand ma fille le dis ça parce
mort et qui n'ont pas d'argent on l'a
aimé aussi c'est parce que nous faisait
rire c'est nous fait plus rire ou chabal
tellement besoin ou envie de l'entendre
parce que des gens qui parlent au nom de
la cause des femmes beaucoup mieux
qu'elle dise ou moins déjà lors par le
président le court aujourd'hui madame
est elle à elle à message à faire passer
on a besoin aussi joe qui ont hélas qui
ont la parole et qui peuvent faire
passer des messages le message aux mains
de robin roy sera beaucoup plus
facilement puisque en plus ça fait plein
de ce rallye avec humour cyril comme des
gens même sens de muriel robin elle est
très drôle
elles étaient invités de on n'est pas
couché là n'était pas seulement elle
était très jeune et moi je crois que
jean marie charon s'est vengé sur on
n'est pas couché et qu'il a trafiqué un
petit peu le plateau regardez
le début des marques que je me prenne un
morceau de décor sur le pied oui c'est
normal que ça tombe sur moi c'est pas
grave j'ai deux priorités deuxième reste
l'autre mais après ça normalement seul
civil fait le reste je pensais bien de
nouveau studio mais c'est vrai je sais
que vous êtes bricoleur
sinon j'aurais envie volonté sauf que là
je suis trop directe vers les prises
électriques
koxie un moment vous voyez avec les
cheveux un peu droit ne sera pas pour
vous faire rire ça sera que je prendrais
de mourir c'est vrai que si on peut
demander quel jean marie bigard et
muriel robin faites nous rire parce que
vous êtes tous les deux tel rôle
et franchement c'est ce qu'on attend
c'est l'humour et les grossesses et 2